have you ever wanted to kill a lot of
zombies and by a lot of zombies i mean
literally every zombie there could ever
be there's really no game that i've ever
played that really showcases zombies
like world war z which is a game that i
actually do like if you look at the top
right there i actually have played it
quite a bit and i like it for the simple
reason that there are a lot of zombies
it's not even like the best shooter i've
ever played it's just that there are a
lot of zombies and recently world war z
came out with an expansion called
aftermath which adds first person mode
which i like very much because the third
person was a little janky not gonna lie
also this video is sponsored by epic
games if you want to get this game for
yourself use my creator code markiplier
in the epic game store on this game or
any game in this store to support me
and then you can kill zombies with me
one of the reasons why i like this game
so much is just because it is
there are a lot of zombies and i like i
like left 4 dead i really do i like a
lot of zombie games but this one just
has more zombies than i've ever seen in
any game
period because it's it's obviously based
on the the movie which is not based on
the book world war z can i tell you that
straight up if you've read the book
world war z it is nothing like the movie
because number one
it's nothing like the movie and say what
you want about fast for slow zombies
slow zombies
are what the book was about fast time is
what the movie was about for a game it
needs to be fast zombies unless there's
a good slow zombie one which is always
possible man i'm gonna i'm gonna show
you what i'm going to show you isn't
just like a highlight reel i'm literally
only going to show you the parts of this
game where there are a lot of zombies
because the rest of it is like whatever
but the whole point of this game is that
there are a lot of zombies anyway let's
play i don't even know how they managed
to get this many zombies
in a game
uh it doesn't matter
so if this seems familiar that's because
it's like a lot like left 4 dead
start i left for dead too anyway so
anyway i'm supposed to be quiet or
whatever but
you know that takes too long
if you think there's a lot of zombies
you're sadly mistaken this is not a lot
of zombies but you're not even seeing
this this is not a lot of zombies
now that
is a lot of zombies
i wish for one moment that i was able to
fight all of those zombies oh wait i can
because there's a lot of zombies down
there
it's like dead rising level of zombies
good i wanted something noisy
there we go now that is what you call
a lot of
zombies that's more like it
you literally knock them hey
hey i'm busy killing a lot of zombies
here and you're
oh well
that's a problem and i should take care
of these a lot of zombies though
it's like the most joy you could have
out of killing a lot of zombies which is
ironically one of my favorite things to
do
i never use this gun which is why it's
not upgraded at all please don't judge
me well that was nice
no i guess we won't be seeing a lot of
zombies in the future that must be the
only time that happens
who this tank wanna be
and the best part about it is you get
traps i love tower defense i've been
playing tower defense games since like
starcraft custom maps with tower defense
in them just because i really like them
but at the same time i feel like this
game has a horde mode right but it
didn't come with a horde mode in the
beginning when it first launched which
seems to me like an incredible oversight
however it still makes up for the fact
that there are a lot of zombies which
i'm gonna show right now why are you
guys all low health because they're dumb
computers that's why i'll play with real
people later but i just wanted to get to
this level so i could show you a lot of
zombies
this is my big gun it helps me kill
those lots of zombies
oh no i'm out of ammo i better not get
another one oops that's a rail i was
shooting
someone please get that off my back
in case it wasn't clear
i like to shoot a lot of zombies
anyway that's all the lot of zombies for
this level so i'm actually done with
this
i'm literally done i literally don't
care unless there's a lot of zombies i
really don't also it's unfortunate that
i'm quitting because i don't get
experience whenever i quit but i don't
care at this point legitimately i just
want to shoot a lot of zombies like
there's a lot of other parts of this
game that you could probably appreciate
you know it's cooperative you get lots
of tools heavy weapons guns and stuff
like that oh that's fine i just really
like shooting a lot of zombies it's like
me with minecraft right all i do in
minecraft is i dig a hole in the ground
that's all i want to do with this game
all i want to do is have one narrow
hallway and a gun with infinite ammo and
if you give that to me i will have just
as much fun as i am with all the story
and the strategy
and the yada
poopty in the
uh
look for the security cards and shoes
claymores on the ground
oh no
you're not watching this this don't
matter there's not a lot of zombies here
don't even worry about it
okay well my computer idiot compadres
are kind of dead the computers are not
really very good
and i think that much should be obvious
but it's not about the computers on my
team it's about the fact that there are
many zombies
well the guys that was a lot of zombies
i feel really confident about our
chances here
uh but that was a that was a tough swarm
that was tough
man you know these zombies they come and
you you know you feel like you're ready
for oh [ __ ]
oh they're coming that way
oh who's screaming
oh boy oh boy
give me give me give me come on come on
come back defense hold hold fence hold
fence
ford fence
nice
excellent
[ __ ] we can hold
hey we can hold
and honestly i i'm tired of the mortar
mortars are very satisfying though but
something about a big machine gun
oh more
now that's nice
oh and there's special zombies but i
don't really care about them because
they're not a lot of them guys we might
want to get in there's a lot of them
uh guys
uh computers
uh computer bros
uh ethan where are you going buddy ethan
oh my god
this this
[Music]
april uh judd where are you where are
you going pal
judd you okay judd
judd you uh
what what
where did he go
oh
i think we got them all oh
danny you okay there
talking up
oh
no
no no
hi ethan hi dinah well anyway
this game is very fun
oh a revolvey there's more zombies at
the end of this level so i'm gonna play
this one through uh also there's like i
don't know there's like people talking
or something
oh hey judd you're back from the dead
good hey guys there's uh zombos coming
i freaking love this game i really do
it's so cathartic if you want a
cathartic experience
of just
shooting a lot of zombies this is your
game
this is your game
and there's like a competitive
multiplayer mode i've literally never
played it and i have no interest in
playing it ever but like oh my god
so many zombies
it's just it's beautiful it's just so
pop
boom
lots of zombies bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang boom
boom boom boom boom boom bang bang bang
bang bang bang boom boom boom boom
there's like there's like levels that
have like objectives or whatever where
you're not trying to kill a lot of
zombies and i'm like what is the point
of those what's the point of all that
it's filler content all i care about is
the killing of a lot of the zombies
the zombies are the ones that i actually
want to kill a lot of bang in here guys
guys in here
i'm going to turn on the fan
and then
oh come on let him
laugh hey
don't shoot them let them burn
oh yeah this next part is like a boring
blue part i don't like this part there's
not a lot of zombies here oh yeah and i
gotta protect green gold he's upstairs
and so i gotta go up and down and up and
down and i gotta go down and then i go
up and then i go down and then i go up
and then i go down and then i go up and
now green goal is not probably not doing
so good
oh you have a melee weapon but it's not
really helpful unless you're a slasher
class to killing a lot of zombies which
is the only thing that i care about in
this game
oh and this guy he blows up but he has
special items i didn't get it that time
because he got too close but i like
strategy doesn't really matter to me i
like the explosion so i like seeing him
and goku boom like if you don't make him
go kaboom he you get some special items
or whatever but that's not very fun to
me anyway see this is not nearly enough
zombies in my opinion just uh i know
what this game is capable of and i feel
like either it's it's giving my computer
a break so it doesn't have to render so
many zombies or
it's just decided to be lame here for
some reason but i'm playing it through
because i know that there's another
portion later on where there are a lot
of zombies hey gringold uh you might
want to watch out there's a big dude
oh
i'll charge you
oh
[Laughter]
what
did i mention this game works perfectly
with no bugs at all all right we're
doing great guys we're doing great guys
he's okay he didn't get bit that whole
time no infections no infections there's
more medi kits down there yeah i should
probably go get some
oh
oh no i came down here at the wrong time
oh no i came down here at the wrong time
running away
bravely oh well he's dead
oh there's nothing we could ever do
about that there's just so little that i
could do i'm on my own now
well that's unfortunate for me
don't
stop it
well that's unfortunate for them uh
there was nothing i could possibly do to
save them
okay well i got you dinah
this is what i really care about this is
what some people call the good [ __ ]
whoa hey bud you know what you know what
makes me uh kind of sad about this game
is like
a lot of the weapons towards the end
they're silenced right because it makes
less noise but also
that's really boring i want to hear loud
kabooms every time i'm shooting my guns
so like this one uh but this is such a
pitiful little
so like you know i really do kind of
want the big kabooms right now we get to
the fun part welcome back here's the
part where there's a lot of zombies ah
that's more like it oh that's the good
stuff that's a good see if you guys
could keep my back clear that'd be great
yeah don't even worry about it don't
even worry about it don't even worry
about it don't even worry about it don't
even worry but that sounds like a kaboom
hey it's that thing where i can actually
get the item out of it oh yeah well let
me open up the choppers
yeah and see you get one of these oh
which is a virus sample which is like
bonus points in case but you know it's
bad if they hit you while you're
carrying it or something like that i
don't know some kind of strategy for
bonus points make it more difficult
i don't really understand it more
uh can you guys keep them off me
oh boy thank you for walking directly
into my gun oh they're not off me are
they
[Applause]
we're being overrun time to get one of
these
ow i did that to myself
ah stop it
oh this is why i need to disinfect or
else i'm gonna die well looks like i'm
gonna die anyway
oh yay i'm alive i don't know how
i'm on a med kit i guess
how did i survive that i have no idea
there we go that's more like it
there we go
okay yeah this calls for one of these
bad
boys oh
yeah
i didn't hear the kaboom but i felt it
in my loins
you got it can you do a slow evac while
i shoot more
that'd be really really really nice if
you could do that for me
yeah hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on a little
longer hold hold a little more a little
more and hang on hold on
hold on and okay now we can go
well maybe just a little bit longer
all right i got six bullets left all
right let's go i guess
it's a delight
holy god i love it and you know it's
crazy it seems like i'm killing
thousands of zombies right but in
reality i'm killing hundreds it makes
you realize just how futile a zombie
apocalypse would be if they actually
were fast zombies like i killed 1700
zombies there that's a lot but also in
america there's like 380 million people
imagine if even half of them turned into
a zombie like trying to kill that many
zombies that's what the book talks about
that's what world wars either book talks
about the futility of it the
impossibility of it just the sheer
mechanics of trying to kill that many
zombies and because it's not just about
the fact that you're killing them it's
the fact that when a zombie dies that
body just doesn't despawn that body
literally will pile up like if you
remember in the movie 300 when like
bodies would just pile up and use it
like an avalanche think of how many
bodies i just put on the ground there
the logistics of just dealing with that
and like getting in the way of like your
line of fire like how do you shoot at
the zombies behind the other zombies
when they just create a wall of zombies
and they suddenly start pouring over you
like even if they're going slow it's
kind of a problem so the book is
actually very good i like the book
anyway you can upgrade your class or
whatever i don't know i don't even care
oh wait no there's a horde mode right so
the horde mode is exactly what it sounds
like it's nothing but just the shooting
of the zombies now what's great about
this mode is because it always is a lot
of zombies now i feel like it could be
better there's another mode that they're
coming out with called horde mode xl and
i'm hoping that the xl means a lot of
zombies and in one straight line i don't
want anything else i don't want multiple
objectives i don't want anything besides
one path and a lot of zombies i've never
wanted anything more i deserve it i
should have it this is what i deserve
and this is what i want like the game
developers like oh we gotta create some
intricacies about it oh we gotta create
some dynamicism and i'm like no you
don't you don't have to create anything
dynamic you
dynamic nothing you just give me
this is exactly what i was hoping for
actually thank you for this you just
give me a lot of zombies and also a lot
of bullets and balance the game around
that
ready and i'm happy literally that's all
i need for happiness
in my life
look at those zombies
actually this is one of the new guns i
was actually hoping to get this
oh that's right i have an ability that
gives me a health boost if i kill a lot
of zombies which is great
because i do kill a lot of zombies i
like this gun you know why i like this
gun because it has a lot of bullets so
that i can kill
a lot of zombies i actually really like
this this is exactly the gun that i
always want forever i only ever want
this gun from now on
by the way this is not a lot of zombies
this introductory early first wave level
of zombies can you imagine if left 4
dead had this many zombies like the
gameplay of left 4 dead
with like this many zombies right
it's not that the gameplay here is bad
but you know sometimes it feels a little
unrefined in terms of the actual
gun play and whatever but god damn is it
good god damn is it good anyway i need
bullets so i can continue to shoot many
many zombies oh we're trying to stop
them from getting to the runway gig
because there's like some evacuation
happening i don't really care but it's
uh the story
that's nice
they should be ready for me
they should be running for me i
literally only want to kill them oh
where's the swarm coming from
that's bad
[Music]
excuse me pardon me
pardon me excuse me reloading just need
to take a nice walk get some fresh air
i love shooting zombies
i love shooting zombies
i
love shooting zombies
i love
shooting zombies
i really really unapologetically love
shooting zombies
and apparently no one else has joined my
game probably because i
[Music]
unappealing
anyway let's do it there's another class
that i should be that um you get ammo in
your uh magazine every time you get like
a head shot
would probably be uh helpful
to
prevent too much amro loss
are you really mark blair oh yeah
all right
cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh look at that i'm done aha
oh yeah
well looks like someone's finally here
all right i have so many points but i
mean like i don't want anything else
besides this gun so i guess i just get a
i'm going to get a med kit so i guess to
heal my dumb ass
boom bang boom bang bang all right i
guess i should actually try hans gonna
start getting harder
i've made it to level 21 on this not
because that's an incredibly
high level but just because i never play
with people that i know
even though i asked
all right so this is where uh the
killing of a lot of zombies changes the
dynamicism because instead of killing a
lot of zombies here we get to kill a lot
of zombies over here
also it seems like a crazy feature but
you see that blue bar in the bottom
right that's the sprint meter that
wasn't there before there was no
indication of when you ran out a sprint
before until suddenly you were out how
do you create a game where you don't
know when you're gonna be out of breath
in a game where you need to run away
from zombies a lot how do you make it so
that you don't know
anyway i'm really pushing it here i
should be up there because a lot of
zombies are going to start being here
real soon-ish
also i had molotovs i i didn't mention
that ever because i don't even feel like
it
don't mind me one one seven
don't mind me
just
shooting by your thighs there we go
we don't really kind of not charging
man he takes a lot of bullets almost
like i shouldn't shoot him in his face
i love how is he not dead how have you
guys not killed him
interesting
got him if you may lay him in the back
or something but meleeing him in the
back isn't nearly as fun as shooting him
in the face
i'm just baiting
you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh okay
here i was trying to fade in
yo
oh sweet
the 117 here's being a big sweetie can't
have that can't have that i really don't
like forward-facing auto turrets i like
auto turrets that cover behind because i
feel like if they're forward-facing
you're going to be shooting that
direction anyway and then they're gonna
run out of ammo whereas if you're having
going back they cover your ass when
things get by you so you don't get bit
in the butt by a zombie which i've heard
is deadly
oh here they come
oh my god here they come
oh the reload on this thing takes so
long
i should get a better class if i want to
do this gun
like gunslinger which is all about
hucking guns at your enemies wow we got
a full house
that's how i do baby that's how i do
i'll save you 117. if i had a medkit i
would heal you right now
but i don't so i won't
see this is the problem they always run
out of ammo great to have extra guns on
the front but what about the guns in the
back no one ever thinks about the lots
of zombies coming in the back
hey what's going on big guy hey what's
up oh no oh no
oh no
anyway i could play this all day i
really could
but i gotta go
so yeah i really do love this game i
think it's fantastic i think it's well
made
it's got a lot of bugs don't get me
wrong it's got a lot of bugs but they've
improved it since aftermath came out and
i like that and that's all i gotta say
about that i think it's great oh and i
get to upgrade my weapon i didn't even
think i was gonna get credit for that i
forgot if you leave horde mode you you
can get that
that's nice who wants this silenced who
would want that who wants it silenced
who in their right mind would want that
silenced
why so anyway if you want to check it
out link is in the description go to the
epic game store use my creator code
markiplier on it to support me with your
purchase thank you everybody so much for
watching and if you see me in the game
yeah that's really me thank you and as
always i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]